every former you know grandpas and
grandmas and great grandmothers always
think that it's the worst time they've
everyone's lived through the worst time
the only argument that we're in the
worst time now is because of social
media and they cancel culture
they've never had to deal with that
you're talking about a different animal
yeah and that the narrative of that
canceled culture
which i think a lot of it is white
people or
it you know doesn't matter race but i
think a lot of they they
they amplify everything because now we
got this you gotta worry about you can
take away
because corporations listen the problem
is that corporations
are gutless and and sometimes they just
rather cancel you and just
fire you well they don't want to there
is recourse gutless in a way
i yes there's requests it sucks when
someone gets fired for something that
isn't even
actionable uh just because it looks bad
for a corporation but at the same time
again let's try and put ourselves in
their shoes if you support shoes
some corporation that fire someone or or
or does something
for the sake of guarding their
reputation like cbs and
canada and nate you name it yeah um if
my job is i'm a i'm a senior vice
president of programming at cbs
and i know that i've worked for 30
[ __ ] years
doing everything i can to get up to the
ladder and now i put food on the table
for my kids by doing this job yes
and i i don't think i know
that the behaviors of one of the people
the behavior of one of the people or a
couple of people
that i employ could very easily
cost everything my whole company can go
under
is that gutless or is that just well
sorry but let me know
let me let me well let me play devil's
advocate here
let's say you are the person who makes
decisions at cbs
and nick cannon has worked for cbs
viacom for the last
20 years if you include nickelodeon 20
years and a grinder
by the way brilliant man brilliant man
he's made
zero mistakes in 20 you know this guy
he's a creator
he created wild and out he's made your
company a ton of money
he hosts you know mass singer on fox you
guys done a million things um
america got talent hosts all these shows
right because well all doing a morning
radio show in l.a
five days a week yeah you host the
biggest morning race show in l.a so he
does all this stuff
he makes one mistake i don't agree with
any of it he [ __ ] up
boy did he [ __ ] there's a wildly stupid
comment eugenics
you're smarter than this nick you're
smart what he said he went out he went
after jews and white people
all right we but you know that guy for
20 years he's come up with all this
content he made one mistake
and you're the owner of cbs you guys who
run [ __ ] you're telling me you've never
made mistakes before
so he should be crucified off the
horrible mistake i don't agree with
any of it now if he came out and made an
apology it was like i realized what i
did wrong
i'm gonna study my history books i'm
gonna go back and learn how the jews
were prosecuting what they've done to
persecute
yeah persecuted and come over here and
the success that they've had i've
learned from my mistakes
20 years of work and because the one
mistake now he
should be [ __ ] voted off the island
you're right and and
one mistake what did he do specifically
bring up his exact quote nick because
you keep asking
yeah and you're it's doing you wrong
it's bad
he really brian he was like flirting
with eugenics like the idea that
white people are biologically you are
less than these people
white people white people are less than
black people
from viacom but uh fox actually he came
out with apologies
let me find the actual clip i can i can
sum it up i mean i i've gone over this
a couple times he essentially said that
the melon
the lack of melanin in the people who
migrated north to
to go to like the norse mountains and
things like that and then don't do it on
youtube
got more white um they are biologically
inferior to the people who are
better prepared to deal with the the
the sun and the earth and and living a
vibrant life
therefore they are the real savages and
that yet they
portray us as the savages
not great pigment on our skin and we're
the savages and white people are evil
and the african-americans actually the
original they're the original jews
that's
that's where i think he stepped in [ __ ]
is that he the the the melanin
not true but then he says we're the real
hebrews and that
then you're starting to get it here's
the other thing he did this podcast a
year
let me see what let me find her first
these are his apologies he did the
podcast a year ago you know that
like that was a year ago wow he banged
his podcast a year ago so it came out
now
i i think maybe he uh he was like
reading the history books and all that
and he got too
deep into it you know what i'm saying
like on one subject but he royally
[ __ ] up
i'm not saying he didn't i don't agree
with anything he's a jew of color
we said blacks are actually the real
jews do you know that do you know that
do you know what that theory is it's a
theory about uh evolutionary biology
theory
he read it out of a book about so so so
the idea is as
our ancestors migrated from close to the
equator in africa
to northern climates you there was less
sunlight it's all about it so
you need to lose the melon in your skin
so you can absorb more sunlight to
create more vitamins i just went to
videos
i i do feel you guys know naked savages
very very said yeah
and i'm going to say this carefully he
begins to allege that people who lack
sufficient melanin are a little less
those without dark skin have a
deficiency that historically forced them
to act out of fear and commit acts of
violence to survive
they had to be savages jewish people
white people europeans among others
people on social media okay i mean
he should probably brush up a little bit
more and talk to people like brett
weinstein about
evolutionary biology all of them all of
it he went down such a slippery slope
and he's been show business so long like
nick you're better than this
again i don't [ __ ] with anything he's
talking about he's royally [ __ ] up
but the body of work over 20 years for
cbs viacom
mtv you and he issues an apology which
his issue is he didn't want to apologize
at first but then he did apologize
which ended up [ __ ] because then the
black people are said uh upset at him
now yeah so you have the jews
and the white's upset then you apologize
and the black people are upset you can't
stick by it so you can't win my only
thing is if you're if you're running a
company
you're telling me you've never made any
mistakes no it's it's true it's
critical the problem though brandon has
had it's that old joke it's like
you can build the sistine chapel and
come up with a cure for cancer
but if you [ __ ] one goat
you're a ghost you're a ghostbuster dude
i mean
at the end of the day if you [ __ ] a goat
yeah i thank you for curing cancer and
thank you for [ __ ] sending a rocket
to them
because it's not like nick molested kids
or murdered somebody or raped somebody
like those
yeah you should never work again but
cena
a comet with no data no obviously he's
uneducated about what's going on
over his body of work and if he could
apologize on that
come on well and also i look i actually
kind of feel bad for the guy because i'm
i'm with you i i think what he said was
downright insulting especially if i was
a jew i was like blown away it was
clumsy
even though the white person pissed me
off imagine you're nick and all right
like like let's look at his career
guy works his ass off he does everything
he can to
to build his career all along the way
every [ __ ] step
the black community's been like that
guy's [ __ ] corny [ __ ] nick cannon he
sucks he's not
okay so you're like dude i gotta do
whatever i can to like
up my because i do legitimately think he
cares about the black community i don't
think he's one of these guys that's
fronting it
i think he's deeply deeply concerned
with like the welfare of the black
community
so the whole time he's like everyone
thinks i'm a [ __ ] corny
cornball i'm gonna do everything i can
to like ingratiate myself
and prove that i'm not i'm not a [ __ ]
cornball i'm just a guy who works hard
and and
uh you know likes to like speak my mind
so then you go and you get this
then corporate america is like well
you're [ __ ]
are you are you not gonna apologize well
then you do
and you you're [ __ ] yourself you know
financially maybe you're looking out for
yourself financially
but now the same black community who's
been picking on you this whole time is
like you [ __ ] sell out
yeah what if you can't guy can't win he
can't win it doesn't help that he was
sitting there talking to professor
griff is that that dude yeah the guy who
got kicked out of public enemy for being
too radical
like that guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean
he's essentially he's like richard
spencer but black
yeah he does not it was a perfect you
can change that by not
being by not saying
to taking groups and saying things about
those groups like they're savages or
animals
that's not going to work right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing